salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
quand on parle des Gaulois je suis sûr
que la première image qui vous vient à
l'esprit c'est
[Musique]
celle d'un guerrier avec des tresses
blondes une grosse moustache et un
casque surmonté de deux ailes sans
lunettes évidemment mais cette image
d'Épinal correspond-t-elle à la réalité
les Gaulois étaient-ils aussi
indisciplinés qu'on le prétend
analphabète et bagarreur avec
l'irréductible Thibault de la chaîne
Histoire appliquée nous faisons
aujourd'hui la part du vrai du faux sur
cette idée fixe à propos de nos fameux
ancêtres
c'est vrai que nous avons énormément
d'idées reçues sur les Gaulois regardez
j'ai dressé ici une liste de tous les
clichés qui leur collent à la peau et
oui effectivement elle est longue comme
mon bras parmi les clichés les plus
répandus il y a bien sûr leur apparence
physique les grosses moustaches les
cheveux longs les cheveux blonds les
tresses pourtant chez les Gaulois les
hommes ne portaient pas tous la
moustache et ils n'avaient pas tous les
cheveux longs et encore moins gras à
l'époque comme c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui le look était fonction de la
mode du moment et du groupe auquel on
appartenait la Gaule n'était pas
uniforme elle était constituée de
différents peuples d'origine celtique
mais qui n'obéissent pas tous au même
code les Gaulois faisaient donc très
attention à leur apparence les Romains
eux-mêmes les décrivent d'ailleurs comme
des gens très soucieux de leur hygiène
et de leurs vêtements ils n'hésitait
d'ailleurs pas à porter de riches bijoux
en or ou en bronze ils auraient même
inventé le savon solide tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui alors vous le voyez
l'image que nous nous faisons des
Gaulois est un mythe un mythe créé de
toutes pièces par les auteurs du XIXe
siècle qui ont largement participé à
colporter une image tronquée de ce
peuple des rustres vivant retran dans
leur utrudimentaire au coeur des forêts
alors que non les Gaulois ne vivaient
pas dans des huttes faites de briquet de
broc les fougères théologiques ont
montré qu'il construisait de vrais
maisons aux formes très variées
rectangulaire ronde ou carrés le plus
souvent ces maisons étaient faites de
bois ou de terre dans certaines régions
comme dans le sud on y trouvait aussi de
la pierre mais c'était beaucoup plus
rare le toit était recouvert de chaume
de tuiles ou de bois certains Gaulois
vivaient à la campagne dans de petites
fermes ou regroupées dans de grandes
exploitations mais aussi surprenant que
cela puisse paraître la grande majorité
vivait en ville de grandes villes
fortifiées que l'on appelle des oppida
un oppidum des oppides parmi les plus
célèbres il y a Alésia ou vibracte en
Bourgogne ou encore gervovie en Auvergne
autrement dit les Gaulois émet autant la
ville que les Romains regardez je vous
ai amené une arme gauloise reconstituée
plus précisément une épée gauloise
Gaulois n'est pas très différente du
glaive romain d'ailleurs le mot glaive
vient du latin Gladius qui vient du
Gaulois Claudio qui veut dire et bien
épée voilà les Gaulois dit-on ne s'en
séparer jamais car il passait leur temps
à se bagarrer entre eux alors vrai faux
et bien un peu des deux je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure les Gaulois ne formaient
pas une nation unique mais un ensemble
de peuples qui occupait le territoire et
partager la même culture à la fois celte
et gauloise il en existait plusieurs
dizaines regroupés en territoire assez
autonomes comme les bituriches du côté
de Bourges laissez-nous en Sologne ou
les armées en Auvergne cet ensemble
était cohérent d'un point de vue
culturel mais les Gaulois n’étaient pas
du tout unifiées d'un point de vue
politique ils n'ont pas un chef unique
ni de gouvernement commun comme peuvent
l'avoir les Romains entre les garçons
donc assez fréquentes on s'embrouille on
salit en fonction des intérêts de chacun
durant la Guerre des Gaules par exemple
il n'est pas rare qu'un peuple sali avec
un autre peuple contre un troisième et
puis finalement pour telle ou telle
raison ils vont devenir ennemis avant de
se réconcilier à nouveau contre Rome par
exemple parce rentre en conflit c'est
guerriers ne se battent pas du tout de
manière totalement anarchique comme on
le voit dans les aventures d'Astérix
bien au contraire les Gaulois excellent
sur le champ de bataille et terrifie
leurs ennemis par leur célèbre tumulte
gaulois ils sont une structurés très
organisés avec une hiérarchie qui est
bien installée grosse différence avec
les Romains c'est que les armées
gauloises ne sont globalement pas
désarmés de métier mis à part quelques
troubles d'élite les soldats sont
recrutés dans la population civile et en
période de paix ces combattants
occasionnels sont agriculteurs artisans
ou commerçants une fois de plus nous
sommes très loin de l'idée reçue du
Gaulois réfractaire rustre et gros
mangeur de sanglier
à propos de sanglier je vais sans doute
décevoir les fans d'Obélix les Gaulois
n'ont consommaient pas on ne trouve
quasiment aucun reste de sanglier dans
les déchets culinaires sur les sites
archéologiques il faut dire que nos
ancêtres avaient une bonne raison de ne
pas en consommer chez eux le sanglier
était un animal sacré qui appartenait à
la forêt donc aux dieux selon la légende
lorsqu'un Gaulois en tué un il devait le
rembourser à la nature en sacrifiant
l'une de ses propres bêtes enfin bon
c'est une légende en revanche ce qui est
sûr c'est que la viande faisait bien
partie de leur régime alimentaire mais
elle provenait principalement de
l'élevage en effet les Gaulois pratiques
l'élevage de boeufs de moutons de chèvre
et de porc sont aussi d'habiles
cultivateurs qui occupent un territoire
qui n'est absolument pas couvert de
forêt comme on l'imagine mais surtout
constitué de zones agricoles bien
entretenues les terres ils sont fertiles
on y cultive de nombreuses céréales
comme le blé et l'orge ainsi que des
lentilles et des légumes ce sont aussi
d'excellents artisans des bijoux des
armes des tissus des aussi les produits
qu'ils fabriquent jouissent d'une
excellente réputation et s'exporte dans
une bonne partie de l'Europe y compris à
Rome c'est l'occasion de tordre le coup
à un autre mythe très tenace si les
Gaulois fabriqués de nombreux objets
d'art en revanche il ne taillait pas les
menhirs absolument pas ces gros blocs de
pierre ont été érigés au Néolithique
entre 2000 et 5000 ans avant
Jésus-Christ donc bien avant leur
arrivée qui signifie que nous sommes
deux fois plus proche du célèbre
Vercingétorix qu'il ne l'est lui-même
des hommes qui ont fabriqué les menhirs
de Carnac en Bretagne c'est quand même
dingue toutes ces idées reçues tiens
encore une qui a la peau dure dans
l'inconscient collectif les Gaulois ne
maîtrisaient pas l'écriture et bien
c'est complètement faux ils ont au
contraire laisser un grand nombre de
traces écrites les premières
inscriptions gauloises date du deuxième
siècle avant Jésus-Christ bien avant
donc l'avènement de Jules César elles
ont été découvertes en Provence et en
Bourgogne elle porte en grande partie
sur des noms propres il y avait sur des
pierres tombales des cruches ou des bols
d'autres font parfois référence
des échanges commerciaux les Gaulois
écrivaient en langue gauloise mais ils
utilisaient l'alphabet grec ou latin
alors ce cliché du Gaulois analphabète
vient d'une mauvaise lecture d'un
passage de la Guerre des Gaules dans ce
bouquin César rapporte que les druides
qui vous les conserver le secret de leur
pratique évite l'usage de l'écriture
pourtant dans ce même passage il est
aussi mentionné que les Gaulois écrivent
pour les affaires courantes
Thibault qu'est-ce que tu regardes j'ai
pas c'est le plafond je n'ai pas
tellement confiance j'ai l'impression
qu'il va me tomber sur la tête si vous
avez lu les aventures d'Astérix vous
connaissez cette célèbre réplique les
Gaulois n'ont peur que d'une chose que
le ciel leur tombe sur la tête vous
pensez peut-être qu'elle a été inventée
de toutes pièces par les auteurs de la
bande dessinée et bien il n'en est rien
en réalité cette histoire date
d'Alexandre le Grand c'est-à-dire bien
avant Astérix Alexandre le grand
conquérant a entendu parler des Gaulois
de ces farouches combattants il a envie
de les rencontrer et les invite à un
grand banquet la fête basse son plein
tout le monde est un peu éméché et
Alexandre leur demande alors qu'est-ce
que vous craignez le plus le Conquérant
ici Satan à ce que les Gaulois disent et
bien on craint les armées d'Alexandre
mais les Gaulois répondent alors qu'il
ne créent qu'une seule chose que le ciel
leur tombe sur la tête Alexandre est un
peu étonné mais trouve que les Gaulois
sont finalement bien courageux la
célèbre phrase vient tout simplement de
là en tout cas ce n'est pas pour se
protéger du ciel qui tombe sur la tête
que les Gaulois portaient des casques
mais bien pour se protéger la tête sur
le champ de bataille vous êtes peut-être
un peu surpris par celui que je porte et
bien effectivement il n'a pas d'elle pas
du tout rien à voir avec celui d'Astérix
ni même avec celui de Vercingétorix tel
qu'on le représente sur les gravures
cette erreur nous vient de dessin
réalisée à la suite des fouilles
archéologiques au 19e siècle à cette
époque on avait mis la main sur des
casques Gaulois très abîmés on a donc eu
des difficultés à mettre au point des
dessins clairs et précis alors on a un
peu improvisé en dessinant ce qui
pouvait s'apparenter à des ailettes mais
qui était en fait des parnatides vous
savez c'est ce qui servait à protéger
les joues sur certains types de casques
antiques en réalité la plupart des
casques Gaulois était assez lisse comme
le mien un casque liste des vies mieux
les coûts et il est aussi beaucoup plus
simple à fabriquer il reste que certains
casques probablement destinés aux
officiers portent des ornements à base
de plumes ou de crainte cheval
exactement comme celui-ci ça les rendait
plus visibles pour leurs hommes durant
le combat les Gaulois fabriqués aussi
parfois des casques qui pourraient vous
sembler très amusants mais dans l'usage
était probablement réservé à des rituels
et non au combat si ton par exemple ces
deux casques impressionnants retrouvés
dans le sanctuaire de Tintignac en
Corrèze là est affublé d'un grand col de
cygne
trois anneaux qui sont réputés
inutilisables au combat car bien trop
lourd et déséquilibré enfin et je sais
que vous l'attendiez est-ce qu'il est
possible qu'il y ait eu un village
irréductible Gaulois qui a résisté
encore et toujours à l'envahisseur
difficile à dire même s'il est bien
resté quelques villes et villages qui
ont résisté au romain bien après Alésia
comme la ville d'uxelodonum dans les
environs de Cahors malheureusement et
bien sans potion magique c'est
défenseurs furent vaincus et subir un
triste sort pour l'exemple merci
Thibault c'était passionnant une gorgée
de Savoie c'est aussi efficace contre
les idées reçues que la potion magique
contre les Romains et puis si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à mettre
un pouce bleu ou à vous abonner et
surtout indiquez-moi en commentaire les
sujets histoire que vous aimeriez que
l'on traite
Panoramix c'est vide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]